>> A STORY IN 5 WORDS NEWSOME
SAYS IMMIGRANTS ARE KIDNAPPED.
KATIE, SO AWESOME, GOVERNOR
NEWSOME ASKED THE DOJ TO LOOK
INTO WHETHER SENDING MIGRANT TO
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY CAN
BE CONSIDERED KIDNAPPING.
WHAT DO YOU CARE?
A, IS HE [BLEEP]
B, IS HE REALLY [BLEEP]?
AND C, A AND B?
>> I THINK THIS IS HILARIOUS.
HE WAN THEM TO INVESTIGATE
KIDNAPPING?  ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
ALSO, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
INVESTIGATION DE SANTIS FOR
KIDNAPPING YOU ALSO HAVE TO
INVESTIGATE JOE BIDEN BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN FLYING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AND BUSING THEM WHERE B
THEY WANT TO GO.
IF THAT'S DE SANTIS IS
INGAININGED IN KIDNAPPING, SO
ARE THESE OTHER PEOPLE JUST LIKE
THEY'RE BRINGING THIS OUT EBB
THE LIGHT FOR EVERYBODY TO SEE
AND IT'S AMAZE TAG WATCH THE WAY
THIS WORKS.
THE LEFT DOES SOMETHING SO THEY
FLY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO ALL
THESE PLACES AROUND THE COUNTRY
THAT ARE NOT MARTHA'S VINEYARD
BECAUSE THAT A VERY FANCY SACKY
VACATION SPOT.
THEY WANT YOU TO INTO THEIR
BACKYARD NOT YOUR FRONT YARD.
THEN THE RIGHT DOES THE SAME
THING THAT THE MORAL, VERY KIND
THING TO DO, SO WE'RE GOING TO
JUST HOLD YOU TO YOUR OWN
STANDARD AND SEND PEOPLE TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
AND THEN TODAY THEY DEPORTED
THEM ALL, 50 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
THEY DEPORTED THEM OF A F
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AFTER CLAIMING
IT WAS INHUMANE TO SHIP THEM EN
THE FIRST PLACE.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN IT WAS A
HORRIBLE IDEA, WHERE DID YOU GET
IT FROM?
>> YOU GUYS.
>> YOU'RE THE ONE WHOSE DID
THIS.
>> IT IS SO -- KAT, I LOVE THIS
STORY MORE AND HER EVERY DAY
BECAUSE THEY GET ANGRIER AND
MORE HI ERICAL ABOUT THIS.
HYSTERICAL ABOUT THIS.
NOW THEY'RE CAUGHT BLACKFOOTED
AND IT'S LIKE GREAT.
I ENJOY IT.
THAT NOT EVEN A QUESTION.
>> I'M GLAD YOU'RE HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE THEN GOING TOUCHABLE
IMMIGRATION BECAUSE WHENNER
IMMIGRATION IS IN THE NEWS IT'S
SOME VARIATION OF YOU SUCK, NO
YOU SUCK, AND IT'S LIKE YOU
NEVER HEAR FROM CONGRESS AT HOW
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO SOLVE
IT.
IT'S A FEDERAL ISSUE THAT HAS TO
BE SOLVED THE FEDERAL GOV 789
AND I HAVEN'T HEARD THEM SAY
ANYTHING.
IT'S JUST THE WAY THEY DID THIS
WAS BAD.
YOU DID THIS THAT WAS BAD.
WE'RE JUST NEVER GOING TO SOLVE
IT AND IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
>> I THINK THIS MADE PROGRESS
BECAUSE IT MADE IT CLEAR TO
EVERYBODY TWO THINGS, ONE, THAT
IT'S NOT BEING SOLVED AND TWO,
THE ONLY REASON YOU DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT BEFORE IS BECAUSE THE
MEDIA HAD THE THUMB ON THE SCALE
THEY NEVER REPORTED THE LATE
NIGHT STUFF EXCEPT TO THE NEW
YORK POST.  AND THEN ON CNN,
THEY COMPARED THE 50 MIGRANTS
ESCAPING VENEZUELA AND BEING
PLACED IN A WONDERFUL PLACE,
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, TO THE
HOLOCAUST.
I THOUGHT CNN WAS MOVING TO THE
MIDDLE BUT I GUESS IT'S THE
MIDDLE OF HELL.
>> YES, AND I LOVE YOUR ARGUMENT
BY THE WAY BECAUSE TAKING IT A
STEP FURTHER THE FACT THAT BIDEN
AND EVERYONE DID IT WITH MINORS
ON BOARD MAKES IT AN ENHANCED
FELONY.
MORE ON THE HOOF THAN GAVIN
NEWSOME IS ADVOCATING.
HE IS THE WORST TO ERB DO IT.
HE WAN THEM TO USE RICO, THAT
WHAT YOU USE FOR THE MAFIA,
THAT'S FOR ORGANIZED CRIME.
HE CALLED IT A FRAUDULENT
SCHEME.
WHAT DO YOU CALL THE SOUTHERN
BORDER?
THIS GUY MEAN WHILE IN HIS OWN
SIDE, HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL
RELEASED THESE STATS HOMICIDES
MASSIVELY SPIKED YET HOMICIDE
ARRESTS DECREASED.
HE SHOULD FOCUS CRIMINAL CHARGES
ON HIS OWN CITIZENS WRATHER THAN
THE 50 THAT WERE DROPPED OFF ON
SOME LUXURY ISLAND SOMEWHERE.
>> THEY'RE SO STUPID.
THE RESPONSE TO THIS.
I CAN'T EVEN EXPRESS THE JOY
THAT I FEEL WATCHING THESE
MELTDOWNS.
>> I AM, I WAS OFFENDED.
I'M UPSET.
>> YES?
>> THE IDEA OF SENDING 50 TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
HOW DARE YOU.
THAT LIKE SHAME ON ALL OF YOU.
250'S THE NUMBER.
250 IS THE NUMBER.
LISTEN, I KNOW YOU LIKE REALITY
SHOWS, I HAVE A PHENOMENAL ONE.
A TRIP ON A BUS WITH TYRUS.  I
WILL PICK YOU UP IN EL PASO AND
TAKE YOU TO ANY BLUE CITY YOU
WANT TO GO.
YOU CAN FILM THE WHOLE THING.
WE WILL STOP AT EVERY MAREK
GOVERNOR, HOUSE, ANYTHING WITH A
DONKEY, WE WILL STOP AND TAKE
PICTURES.
IT WILL BE PHENOMENAL AND I'LL
DROP YOU OFF AND JUST THE KINAP
THING, ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
IT'S FILMED WHEN THEY GET ON AND
THEY'RE GETTING ON LIKE THIS?
AND THEY'RE GETTING OFF LIKE
THIS.
>> YEAH.
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN KIDNAPPED
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS, BUT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE COMING BACK FROM
KIDNAPPING IS LIKE HOW WAS IT?
>> IT'S SO TRUE.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN KIDNAPPED
EITHER.
>> IS THERE ANYONE EN THE
AUDIENCE AVAILABLE FOR A
KIDNAPPING.
>> DON'T EGG ON THE KIDNAPPING
OF KAT EBEN THOUGH THAT GREAT
NYMPH A SHOW.
THE KIDNAPPING OF KAT TIMPF,
HOSTED BY NANCY GRACE.
LAST TIME WE SAW KAT TIMPF.
>> I WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> I WOULD HATE IT BECAUSE THEY
WOULD 1,000 PERCENT BLAME ME.
>> I WOULD DEFENSE ME.
>> IMAGINE THE ATTENTION I WOULD
GET.
>> I THINK THERE'D BE NO WAY.
UP NEXT YOU THINK YOU'LL GET